PROFESSOR: We ask about
averages all the time.
And in the context
of random variables,
averages get abstracted
into a lovely concept
called the expectation
of the random variable.
Let's begin with a
motivating example
which, as is often the case,
will come from gambling.
So there's a game
that's actually
played in casinos called
Carnival Dice where you have
three dice, and the
way you play is you
pick your favorite
number from 1 to 6,
whatever it happens to be.
And then you roll
the three dice.
The dice are assumed to be
fair, so each one of them
has a one in six
chance of coming up
with any given number.
And then the payoff
goes as follows.
For every match of your
favorite number, you get $1.00.
And if none of your favorite--
if none of the die show
your favorite number,
then you lose $1.00.
OK.
Let's do an example.
Suppose your favorite
number was five.
You announce that to the
house, or the dealer,
and then the dice start rolling.
Now if your roll happened to
come up with the numbers two,
three, and four, well,
there's no fives there,
so you've lost $1.00.
On the other hand, if your
rolls came out five, four, six,
there's one five,
you've one $1.00.
If it came out five, four,
five, there's two fives,
you've won $1.00.
And if it was all fives,
you've actually won $3.00.
Now real carnival dice is often
played where you either win
or lose $1.00 depending on
whether there's any match
at all, but we're playing
a more generous game where,
if you double match,
you get $2.00.
If you triple match,
you get $3.00.
So the basic question about
this is, is this a fair game.
Is this worth playing, and
how can we think about that?
Well, we're going to think
about it probabilistically.
So let's think about
the probability
of rolling no fives.
If five is my favorite
number, what's
the probability that
I roll none of them?
Well, there's a five
out of six chance
that I don't roll a
five on the first die,
and on the second die
and on the third die.
And since the die rolls are
assumed to be independent,
the dies are independent,
the probability of no fives
is 5/6 to the third, which
comes out to be 125/216.
I'm writing this
out because we're
going to put all
the numbers over 216
to make them easier to compare.
OK.
What's the probability
of one five?
Well, the probability
of any single sequence
of die rolls with a single five
is 5/6 of no five times 5/6
of no five times
1/6 of one five.
And there are 3 choose 1
possible sequences of dice
rolls with one five, and
the others non-fives.
Likewise, for two
fives, there's 3
choose 2 times 5/6
to the 1, which
is one way of choosing the
place that does not have a five.
And 1/6 times 1/6, which is
the probability of getting
fives in the other places.
I didn't say that well, but
you can get it straight.
OK.
The probability of three fives
is the probability of 1/6
of getting a five on
the first die, 1/6
of getting a five on the
second die, 1/6 of getting
a five on the third die.
It's simply 1/6 cubed.
OK, so we can easily
calculate these probabilities.
This is a familiar exercise.
Let's put them in a chart.
So what we've figured
out is that 0 matches has
a probability of 125 over 216.
And in that case, I lose $1.00.
One match turns out to have a
probability of 75 out of 216,
and I win $1.00.
Two matches is 15 out
of 216, I win $2.00.
And three matches, there's
one chance in 216 that I win
the $3.00.
So now I can ask about
what do I expect to win.
Suppose I play 216
games, and the games
split exactly according
to these probabilities.
Then what I would expect
is that I would wind up
with 0 matches about 125 times.
That was the probability
of there being no matches.
It was 125/216.
So if I played 216
games, I expect about 125
are going to-- I'm
going to win nothing.
Or, I'm going to get no matches,
which actually means I'll lose
$1.00 on each.
One match I expect
about 75 times.
2 matches, 15 times.
3 matches, once.
So my average win is going to be
125 times minus 1, 75 times 1,
15 times 2 plus 1
times 3 divided by 216.
So these numbers on the top were
how the 216 rolls split among
my choices of losing $1.00,
winning $1.00, winning $2.00,
and winning $3.00.
And it comes out to
be slightly negative.
It's actually minus $0.08--
minus 17/216 of $1.00,
which is about minus $0.08.
So I'm losing, on the
average, $0.08 per roll.
This is not a fair game.
It's really biased against me.
And if I keep
playing long enough,
I'm going to find
that I average out
a kind of steady loss
of about $0.08 a play.
So we would summarize
this by saying
that you expect to
lose $0.08, meaning
that your average loss is $0.08
and you expect that that's
going to be the
phenomenon that comes up
if you keep playing the game
repeatedly and repeatedly.
It's important to
notice, of course,
you never actually lose
$0.08 on any single play.
So what you-- this notion of
your expecting to lose $0.08,
it never happens.
It's just your average loss.
Notice every single play
you're either going to lose $1,
win $1, win $2, win $3.
There's no $0.08
at all showing up.
OK.
So now let's abstract
the expected value
of a random variable
R. So a random variable
is this thing that
probabilistically
takes on different values
with different probabilities.
And its expected
value is defined
to be its average value where
the different values are
weighted by their probabilities.
We can write this out
as a precise formula.
The expectation of
a random variable R
is defined to be the sum over
all its possible values-- it
doesn't indicate what
the summation is,
but that's over all
possible values v-- of v
times the probability
that v comes up,
the probability
that R equals v. So
this is the basic
definition of the expected
value of a random variable.
Now let me mention here
that this sum works
because since we're assuming
accountable sample space,
R is defined on only
countably many outcomes,
which means it can only
take countably many values.
So this is a countable sum
over all the possible values
that R takes, because there are
only countably many of them.
And what we've just
concluded, then,
is the expected win in
the carnival dice game
is minus 17/216.
Check this formal definition
of the expectation
of a random variable versus
the random variable defined
to be how much you win on a
given play of carnival dice,
and it comes out
to be that average.
Minus 17/216.
Now there's a
technical result that's
useful in some proofs that
says that there's another way
to get the expectation.
The expectation can
also be expressed
by saying it's the sum over
all the possible outcomes
in the sample space--
S is the sample
space-- of the value of the
random variable at that outcome
times the probability
of that outcome.
So this is another
alternative definition of
compared to saying
it's the sum over all
the values times the
probability of that value.
Here, it's the sum
over all the outcomes
of the value of the
random variable,
the outcome times the
probability of the outcome.
It's not entirely obvious
that those two definitions
are equivalent.
This form of the
definition turns out
to be technically
helpful in some proofs,
although outside of
proofs you don't use it
so much in applications.
But it's not a bad exercise
to prove this equivalence.
So I'm going to
walk you through it.
But if it's boring-- it's kind
of a boring series of equations
on slides, and you're
welcome to skip past it.
It is a derivation that I expect
you to be able to carry out.
So let's just carry
out this derivation.
I'm going to prove
that the expectation is
equal to the sum over all
the outcomes of the value
of the random variable at the
outcome times the probability
of the outcome.
And let's prove it.
In order to prove it, let's
begin with one little remark
that's useful.
Remember that this
notation R equals
v describes the event that the
random variable takes the value
v, which by definition is an
event is the set of outcomes
where this property holds.
So it's the set of outcomes
omega where R of omega
is equal to v. So let's just
remember that, that brackets
R equals v is the
event that R is
equal to v, meaning the set
of outcomes where that's true.
So what that tells
us in particular
is that the
probability of R equals
v is, by definition, the
sum of the probabilities
of the outcomes in the event.
So it's the sum over
all those outcomes.
Now let's go back to
the original definition
of the expectation of R.
The original definition is--
and the standard one is-- it's
the sum over all the values
of the value times
the probability
that the random variable
is equal to the value.
Now on the previous
slide, we just
had a formula for
the probability
that R is equal
to v. It's simply
the sum over all the outcomes
of where R is equal to v,
of the probability
of that outcome.
So I can replace
that term by the sum
over all the outcomes of the
probability of the outcome.
OK.
So I'm trying to head
towards an expressions that's
only outcomes, which is kind
of the top-level strategy here.
So the first thing
I did was I got rid
of that probability
of v and replaced it
by the sum of all
these probabilities--
of the probabilities
of all the outcomes
where R is v. Well, next step
is I'm going to just distribute
the v over the inner sum.
And I get that this thing
is equal to the sum,
again, over all those outcomes
in R equals v of v times
the probability of the outcome.
But look, these outcomes are the
outcomes where R is equal to v.
So I could replace
that v by R of omega.
That one slipped
sideways a little bit,
so let's watch that.
This v is simply going
to become an R of omega.
I'm still [INAUDIBLE] over
the same set of omegas,
but now I've gotten rid
of pretty much everything
but the omegas.
So I've got this inner sum of
over all possible omegas in R
of v of R of omega times
the probability of omega.
And I'm summing
over all possible v.
But if I'm summing over
all possible v and then
all possible outcomes
where R is equal to v,
I wind up summing over
all possible outcomes.
And so I've finished the proof
that the expectation of R
is equal to the sum over all
the outcomes of R of omega times
the probability of omega.
Now I'd never do a proof
like this in a lecture,
because I think watching
a lecturer write stuff
on the board, a whole
bunch of symbols
and manipulating equations,
is really insipid and boring.
Most people can't
follow it anyway.
I'm hoping that in the
video, where you can go back
if you wish and replay it
and watch it more slowly,
or at your own
speed, the derivation
will be of some value to you.
But let's step back a
little bit and notice
some top-level technical
things that we never
really paid attention to
in the process of doing
this manipulative proof.
So the top-level
observation, first of all,
is that this proof, like many
proofs in basic foundations
of probability theory
and random variables,
in particular, involves
taking sums and rearranging
the terms in the sums a lot.
So the first question
is, why sums?
Remember here we
were summing over all
the possible variables,
all the possible values
of some random variable.
Why is that a sum?
Well it's a sum because we
were assuming that the sample
space was countable.
There were only a
countable number
of values R of omega 0, R
of omega 1, R of omega n,
and so on.
And so we can be
sure that the sum
over all the possible values
of the random variable
is a countable sum.
It's a sum, and we don't have
to worry about integrals, which
is the main technical
reason why we're
doing discrete probability and
assuming that there are only
a countable number of outcomes.
There's a second very
important technicality
that's worth mentioning.
All the proofs involved
rearranging terms
in sums freely and without care.
But that means that
we're implicitly
assuming that it's safe to do
that, and that, in particular,
that the defining
sum for expectations
needs to be
absolutely convergent.
And all of these sums
need to be absolutely
convergent in order for
that kind of rearrangement
to make sense.
So remember that
absolute convergence
means that the sum of the
absolute values of all
the terms in the sum converge.
So if we look at this
definition of expectation,
it said it was the sum over
all the values in the range.
We know that's a
countable sum of the value
times the probability that
R was equal to that value.
But the very definition
never specified
the order in which these terms,
v times probability R equals v,
got added up.
It better not make a difference.
So we're implicitly assuming
absolute convergence
of this sum in order
for the expectation
to even be well-defined.
As a matter of fact,
the terrible pathology
that happens-- and
you may have learned
about this in
first-time calculus,
and we actually have
a problem in the text
about it-- is that you can have
sums like this, that are not
absolutely convergent, and then
you pick your favorite value
and I can rearrange
the terms in the sum
so that it converges
to that value.
When you're dealing with
non-absolute value sums,
rearranging is a no-no.
The sum depends
crucially on the ordering
in which the terms
appear, and all
of the reasoning and probability
theory would be inapplicable.
So we are implicitly assuming
that all of these sums
are absolutely convergent.
Just to get some
vocabulary in place,
the expected value is also known
as the mean value, or the mean,
or the expectation of
the random variable.
Now let's connect up
expectations with averages
in a more precise way.
We said that the
expectation was kind
of an abstraction of
averages, but it's more
intimately connected to
averages than that, even.
Let's take an
example where suppose
you have a pile of graded exams,
and you pick one at random.
Let's let S be the score of
the randomly picked exam.
So I'm turning this process,
this random process of picking
an exam from the pile, is
defining a random variable, S,
where by definition of
picking one at random,
I mean uniformly.
So S is actually not a
uniform random variable,
but I'm picking the exams
with equal probability.
And then they have
different scores,
so the outcomes are of
uniform probability.
But S is not,
because there might
be a lot of outcomes, a lot
of exams with the same score.
All right.
S is a random variable
defined by this process
of picking a random exam.
And then you can just check
that the expectation of S
now exactly equals the
average exam score, which
is the typical
thing that students
want to know when the exam is
done, what's the average score.
Actually, the average
score is often
less informative than the
median score, the middle score,
but people somehow
rather always want
to know about the averages.
The reason why the average
may not be so informative
is because-- well, it has some
weird properties that I'll
illustrate in a second.
But the point here
of what we did
where we took the-- we got at
the average score on the exam
by defining a random variable
based on picking a random exam.
So that's a general process.
We can estimate averages in
some population of things
by estimating the expectations
of random variables
based on picking random
elements from the thing
that we're averaging over.
That's called sampling,
and it's a basic idea
of probability theory
that we're going
to be able to get
a hold of averages
by abstracting the
calculation of an average
into taking-- defining
a random variable
and calculating its expectation.
Let's look at an example.
It's obviously impossible
for all the exams
to be above average,
because then the average
would be above average.
That's absurd.
So if you translate that
into a formal statement
about expectations, it
translates directly--
by the way, I don't know
how many of you listen
to the Prairie Home Companion,
but one of the sign-offs
there is at the town of
Lake Woebegone in Wisconsin,
where all the children
are above average.
Well, t'ain't possible.
That translates into
this technical statement
that the probability
that a random variable is
greater than its expected
value is less than 1.
It can't always be greater
than its expected value.
That's absurd.
On the other hand, it's actually
possible for the probability
that the random variable is
bigger than its expected value
to be as close to 1 as you want.
And one way to
think about that is
that, for example,
almost everyone
has an above average
number of fingers.
Think about that for a second.
Almost everyone has an above
average number of fingers.
Well, the explanation
is really simple.
It's simply because
amputation is much more
common than polydactylism.
And if you can't understand
what I just said,
look it up and think about it.